bonjour baptiste robert merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france on sait que à la pandémie de
courant navires us régressent
si elle disparaît quel avenir pour ce
top cow vie de l'application à terme sur
est elle vouée à disparaître ou bien
être utilisé sur une voie annexe pour
tracer les gens en quête de nouvelles
épidémies ou en tête conflits sociaux
majeurs alors cette application a été
instauré avec un cadre très précis et de
base dès le départ l'idée de cette
application était qu'elle ne dure pas
dans le temps et qu'elle ce que son
utilisation soit limitée donc
aujourd'hui de mémoire je crois qu'on
est parti sur une utilisation jusqu'à la
fin de l'année au maximum pour ce qu
vide la cnil a validé l'application la
été testé sur une soixantaine de
militaires et personne n'a réussi à
priori à la haac est ce qu'il n'ya pas
un risque quand même à terme alors la
cnil a rendu deux avis effectivement
avec un certain nombre de questions et
certaines recommandations que le
gouvernement a dû auquel le gouvernement
a dû répondre concernant le fait que
l'application d'apple était à quai ce
n'est pas absolument vrai plus qu'il ya
eu effectivement un bug bounty une
chasse aux bugs qui a été organisées en
privé ces derniers jours dont je faisais
partie et on a réussi à trouver certains
problèmes de sécurité alors pas des gros
problèmes de sécurité rien de
catastrophique mais on a remonté
certains problèmes de sécurité qui
depuis ont été réglés et qui je l'espère
seront seront fixés seront réparés dans
la version qui sera sur le pstore mais à
venir il peut y en avoir d'autres
alors un système qu'elle que ce que ce
soit stock co vide ou un autre un
système informatique une application
mobile un site internet il ya toujours
des failles de sécurité
donc un attaquant qui a assez d'efforts
qui a assez de motivation qui a assez de
moyens pour a trop toujours trouver les
failles de sécurité cependant sur ce top
cow vie dans les camps même sur une
application qui a très très peu de
fonctionnalités basiquement vous pouvez
allumer le bluetooth est rentré votre
code que vous avez obtenus lors d'un
dépistage donc la surface d'attaqué très
petit
donc si on trouve des failles de
sécurité sur
ce top cow vite si on a loupé des choses
de ce qui est entièrement possible les
problèmes de sécurité ne seront pas très
très grave pas catastrophique qui a rien
d'irréparable stop qu'ovide a fait
l'objet de nombreuses polémiques
beaucoup parlent d'une application peut
être liberticide
on sait qu aux etats unis le commissaire
de la sécurité publique du minnesota de
jeunes harrington a dit sur nbc news
qu'on commençait à aux états unis de
tracer les manifestants arrêtés lors des
dernières manifestations l'objectif
c'est de localiser et d'identifier
certains groupes d'activistes ce genre
de processus est ce qu'il pourrait
arriver en france
alors effectivement c'est cette
application les applications de contact
racing qui ont vu le jour un peu partout
dans le monde que ce soit en france ou
ailleurs pose plusieurs questions
elle pose la question des libertés
individuelles c'est un recul sur les
libertés individuelles qu'est ce qu'on
va demander aux gens sous prétexte sous
un motif impérieux ici locaux vides 19
hier c'était le terrorisme mais on
demande aux gens d'allumer en d'allumer
en permanence le bluetooth et demain on
vous demandera par exemple peut-être
d'allumer votre gps d'allumer votre wifi
il ya aucune raison et on n'est même pas
demain plus que par exemple en inde
l'application de contacts racing
indienne ou utilise le gps et le
bluetooth pour pour faire du contact
racing donc il ya aucune raison que
demain on vous demande pas un petit peu
plus c'est le problème de faire des
exceptions dans ce domaine c'est à dire
que quand on fait une exception de
l'exception devient souvent la règle est
ici on est en train de on est en train
de demander aux gens on est en train de
faire accepter aux gens que parfois
c'est cesser valide de laisser ouvert
son gps ou ses valises de laisser ouvert
son bluetooth pour pour un certains
motifs j'occupe également les dérives en
france prochainement
c'est plus c'est plus une question de
mentalité et c'est un pas pour moi ce
top cow vide est un petit pas vers un
modèle de société dont je ne veux pas
stop covin n'est pas grave en soi ce
n'est pas catastrophique mais c'est un
petit pas vers un modèle de société dont
je ne souhaite pas et où on peut voir
déjà les
les problèmes puisque pour reprendre
l'exemple de l'inde aujourd'hui
l'application de contacts racing n'est
pas obligatoire mais par contre si vous
voulez accéder à des services du type
prend le train prendre l'avion
vous êtes obligés d'avoir l'application
installée
donc on peut voir qu'à l'étranger il ya
déjà des dérives sur ce type
d'application de contact racing c'est
pour ça que ne créons pas d'exception et
abandonnons pour moi ce système là qui
aujourd'hui n'a absolument pas prouvé
son utilité puisque on peut voir que
partout dans le monde les applications
de contact racing on se sont révélés
pour le moins unique inutile puisqu'on
peut voir par exemple en australie il ya
six millions de personnes qui ont
téléchargé l'application
ils ont réussi à identifier une personne
en islande la même chose ils ont eu une
adoption très très forte 40% et ils ont
affirmé que ce n'était pas très utile ça
leur avait servi à la marche de la même
manière à singapour
ils ont ils ont fait un retour sur
l'expérience et le chef des services
numériques la base s'est bien exprimé en
disant que le contact racing les
applications n'était pas ce n'est pas la
panacée et que ça devait rester un
process manuels plus que derrière on
avait des humains c'est l'humain c'est
des gens qui sont malades
il faut leur parler il faut les
convaincre lorsqu'ils ont faut les
convaincre de rester chez eux et tout ça
doit se faire de personne à personne et
par des professionnels pour analyser les
contacts et ce à une application mobile
n'est pas capable réellement de faire
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
la sortie ce week end de jacques toubon
le défenseur des droits qui a alerté en
dimanche sur des armes des algorithmes
le site qui ne serait pas neutre et que
ce genre de question doit se poser avec
la sphère du coc vide 19 donc ou de déni
des risques liberticide des différentes
implications de traçage 1
avant c'est un bon débat et c'est je
pense qu'il serait salvateur d'avoir ce
débat en français c'est le problème que
que j'ai vu depuis bientôt deux mois en
france c'est à dire que on a tout de
suite posé le débat en disant il nous
faut une ap de contact racing et c'est
un problème sur les libertés publiques
sauf que on a on ne s'est jamais posé la
question de savoir si ces applications
de contact racing était vraiment utile
et qu'est-ce que ça qu'est ce que cela
pouvait engendrer
vers quel modèle de société on voulait
aller
ces débats-là sur les libertés
individuelles ils sont très intéressants
et il faudrait qu'on les ait qu'on les
ait en amont et ici on voit bien qu'on a
essayé de faire une application plus que
c'était la mode singapour a lancé la
mode et tout le monde s'est rué vers ce
type d'application et on va on voit bien
qu'on a fait ça dans l'urgence ils ont
fait une application en deux mois ce qui
est un record est ce qu est ce qui
justement sacrée peur justement je
m'épargne vous coupez le faire en deux
mois
certes c'est peut-être une prouesse
technique mais le faire alors que
l'épidémie est en train de
de se tasser de régresser est-ce que ce
pas trop tard non alors c'est bien la
question c'est à dire que pendant ces
deux mois là c'est ce dispositif qui n'a
pas prouvé son inefficacité encore une
fois et qui au contraire on peut le voir
à l'étranger prouve plutôt son
inefficacité
peut-être que passer deux mois c'est de
prouver au lieu d'effectuer cette
prouesse technique on aurait pu faire
autre chose on aurait pu par exemple
recruté des brigades bien plutôt de
brigades de contact racer on aurait pu
créer des outils le numérique est un
outil puissant et un peu et quitte un
outil qui peut être très utile
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu créer des
outils pour les contacts racer ça ça
fait un long moment que le dit également
est ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu créer des
outils pour lutter contre la solitude de
nos plus anciens par exemple pour
faciliter la communication entre les
plus anciens et les familles pour dans
les ehpad pour permettre aux gens de
dialoguer malgré la distanciation
sociale ce type ce type d'initiative et
je suis certain qu'ils ont été en a eu
quelques-unes mais qui n'héritent ray
plus de lumière d'une application de
contact racines qui au final ne sera pas
vraiment réputé merci baptiste robert
d'avoir répondu à nos questions sur arte
france rappelle que vous êtes chercheur
en cybersécurité